[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du statut de culture aujourd'hui
nous sommes au théâtre de sartrouville
voici le sommaire le théâtre de
sartrouville propose une programmation
riche pour le début de saison 2022 de
nombreux spectacles mais aussi un
festival auront lieu début janvier nous
parlerons du programme avec le directeur
du théâtre l'exposition fantaisie pour
un pâle est actuellement présentée au
château de rambouillet des scènes
inspirées des contes de fées sont à
découvert jusqu'au 6 mars prochain et
puis enfin le festival électro chic est
de retour pour une sixième édition au
programme des artistes reconnus et
émergents se produiront sur les scènes
des théâtres de l'agglomération vers 5
ans park
[Musique]
je me trouve dans la petite salle du
théâtre de sartrouville qui compte
environ 230 place une programmation
riche cette année entre théâtre musique
ou encore danse silva meurice bonjour
vous êtes le directeur du théâtre alors
cette année une belle programmation
combien de spectacle cette année on a
quarante trois spectacles c'est une
année qui est un peu particulière parce
qu'on a bénéficié beaucoup des reports
liés à la crise sanitaire
mais c'est une programmation comme vous
l'avez noté qui est très varié avec
toutes les disciplines du spectacle
vivant qui sont représentés est-ce que
vous pouvez peut-être me parler de cette
programmation de la saison à 2022 le
début janvier à mi-février voilà début
janvier il ya un projet d'une actrice
metteuse en scène qui s'appelle se fit
cusset qui s'appelle wonder woman
enterre son papa alors voilà on peut
l'entendre de façon ironique et tendre à
la fois
c'est un spectacle de cabaret on va dire
sur un sujet qui peut apparaître un peu
triste comme le nom l'indiqué elle elle
en a fait quelque chose
où il ya beaucoup d'humour il ya
beaucoup notamment
à l'appareil wonder woman voilà donc
s'il ya des chansons de la musique comme
des numéros de cabaret une fois de plus
et puis un deuxième spectacle alors là
que j'ai fait moi il s'agit de la fête
des roses
qu'on joue sur une longue série ça
s'appelle la fête des roses
c'est d'après un auteur qui s'appelle
kleist et c'est donc avec une actrice
qui s'appellent norah krief et deux
musiciens et qui raconte l'histoire de
la reine des amazones ces caisses qui
parle de l'émancipation de la liberté du
pnue des femmes très bien pas super une
belle programmation en tout cas et de
nombreux spectacles on vous l'avait dit
nous nous avons pu assister au spectacle
une télévision française regardez
dès 1986 à 1994 l'avis de la rédaction
de tf1 les conférences de rédaction le
journal télévisé les reportages voilà de
quoi parle une télévision française
cette pièce de théâtre raconte surtout
le grand chamboulement de cette chaîne
de télévision sa privatisation en 1987
tf1 est une chaîne du service public et
le gouvernement de jacques chirac décide
de la vendre et de la vendre au groupe
bouygues et donc je raconte comment le
gros bouygues et à transformer cette
chaîne en profondeur la transformer en
une chaîne très performante mais aussi
très commercial et du coup j'analyse un
petit peu avec les acteurs comment tout
ça à modifier les contenus de
l'information une époque de transition
pour l'entreprise le metteur en scène a
voulu réaliser cette pièce puisque tf1
fait partie du patrimoine français j'ai
eu envie que les gens puissent se
retrouver
et avoir un comme un phare tout pouvoir
identifier de quoi ça parlait et donc
j'ai pris un peu une chaîne consensuel
grand public puissante pour raconter et
bien l'information d'aujourd'hui la
création d'une chaîne d'informations en
continu via le groupe tf1 mais aussi les
séries américaines sont autant de
changements pour cette chaîne se la
raconte aussi l'histoire d'une époque
beaucoup d'événements marquants eu lieu
je raconte les élections mitterrand
chirac la rivalité la mort de malik
oussékine cheval de sartrouville aussi
les évènements qui ont eu en 1991 en
banlieue là juste à côté la cité des
indes quand un jeune maghrébin s'est
fait tuer par un vice il raconte les
premières émeutes trois heures de
spectacle dix acteurs sur scène des
journalistes inventé cette pièce sera
visible également au théâtre des
abbesses à paris durant tout le mois de
janvier
on va maintenant parler du festival
odyssée en yvelines c'est le théâtre de
sartrouville en partenariat avec le
département qui organise cette 13ème
édition alors sylvain maurice est ce que
vous pouvez peut-être me présenter ce
festival voilà alors odyssée c'est un
peu notre bébé
je dis ça parce que
c'est à la fois au centre de notre
activité de création donc on fait naître
des spectacles mais c'est aussi parce
que ce sont des spectacles qui s'adresse
aux enfants odyssée sont six créations
originales
qui vont voir le jour
[Musique]
sur l'ensemble de notre territoire les
yvelines ont fait 25 mille kilomètres en
deux mois de la mi janvier à peu près à
la mi mars où on arpente les yvelines
avec six spectacles qui se joue dans des
salles qui ne sont pas équipés des
records on n'est pas obligé d'avoir un
théâtre pour rejouer ses spectacles on
les joue ça peut être un préau d'une
école ça peut être un même un foyer
rural ça peut être un peu tout ce qu'on
veut alors peut-être est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus sur ces six
créations que l'on peut voir ce qui les
caractérise peut-être c'est comment on
fait dialoguer le théâtre et la musique
le théâtre et la danse
le théâtre les arts plastiques etc donc
on a deux spectacles où c'est plutôt le
théâtre et la musique c'est la chanteuse
et compositrice claire diterzi
qui fait le spectacle qui s'appelle
puisque c'est comme ça je vais faire un
opéra tout seul il ya david lescot qui
est auteur metteur en scène qui fait
depuis que je suis née il ya julia vidit
qui montrent un texte de catherine
verlaguet qui s'appelle dissolution est
là qui se rapporte plutôt
à une sorte de conte un peu intemporel
il ya baptiste aman qui propose un texte
d'une enfant qui est dans sa chambre
et qui aurait vous bien ne dort pas
voilà qui avant tout son monde il ya
marion lévy qui y fait et si tu danses
qui donc comme son nom l'indiqué propose
pour les plus petits à partir de 4 ans
l'idée voilà de comment
percevoir son corps et puis pour les
collégiens uniquement salle de classe ça
c'est pas un spectacle joué dans les
criques n'est pas avare alors parfois
qui s'infiltrent dans les salles de
classe qui voilà qui règle celle de
nicole génovèse voilà il ya une chose
qui est très importante qu'il faut
absolument pas pu oublier de vous dire
c'est qu'on a une semaine
à la mi-janvier vous là aussi vous
pouvez trouver des dates exactes qui
s'appelle cité odyssée on peut voir les
cinq spectacles au théâtre très bien
merci beaucoup sylvain maurice paire
avec notre invité jean pris avec plaisir
d'autres salles de théâtre prépare aussi
la rentrée 2022 avec des spectacles de
tous genres comme au prisme à elancourt
sur les planches le 12 février découvrir
kad merad claudia tagbo et lionel
abelanski dans une comédie sur l'amitié
nommé amis enfin le 12 mars deux
artistes sur scène hawaï et jp by many
and black belt entre folk et soul de
voix différentes qui vont vous
transportez tour at war au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le directeur
lionel masse et à nous dévoiler les
trois spectacles qui vont marquer ce
début de saison 2010 je pense qu un des
temps forts du début de la saison ça va
être l'accueil de la tempête
de shakespeare par par peter brook peter
brook c'est un metteur en scène
absolument emblématique de la scène
internationale c'est à la fois un
théoricien du théâtre un praticien du
théâtre pour qui le matériau principal
ou les matériaux principaux ce sont les
comédiens et les personnages et avec la
tempête il a vraiment trouvé une oeuvre
à sa mesure un des deuxième temps fort
de la saison c'est un temps très
événementiel puisque pour la première
fois au théâtre de saint quentin nous
allons accueillir l'orchestré de l'opéra
national de paris qui sort finalement
assez peu de ses murs de bastille ou de
garnier et là le côté encore plus
exceptionnel c'est que lorqu'elle sera
dirigée par gustavo dudamel qui les
nouveaux chefs avec un programme
qui commencera avec des notations de
pierre boulez cdf qui sont assez
rarement interprétés par des orchestres
il va y avoir la symphonie titan c'est
la symphonie numéro 1 de mahler là aussi
une des oeuvres qui a beaucoup évolué au
fil de la vie de mahler puisqu'il a
travaillé pendant quinze ans sur
l'évolution de cette et sur l'écriture
de cette de cette symphonie il ya un
spectacle auquel nous tenons
particulièrement ces piquets qui
s'appelle le fic
par le cirad cirque acrobatique de
danger le cirque acrobatique de danger
existe depuis 20 ans maintenant les les
artistes des acrobates les circassiens
comment autrement dit se renouvelle
chaque
quasiment pas chaque saison mais tous
les deux ans trois ans et ce cirque
acrobatique a aussi une mission sociale
qui est de donner un travail à des
jeunes artistes
marocains
[Musique]
fantaisie pour un palais c'est le nom de
cette exposition qui vous fera voyager à
côte sur des décors à l'aspect féerique
pour vous faire découvrir l'histoire des
contes de fées un genre littéraire à la
mode au xviiie siècle cette exposition
est à découvrir jusqu'au 6 mars prochain
des jeux de lumière des décors fleuris
fantaisie pour un palais un objectif
vous transporter dans le monde des
contes de fées ce nouveau genre
littéraire trouve sont l'essence à la
fin du xviie et début du xviiie siècle
dans la société aristocratique pour cela
plusieurs scènes sont installées au
château de rambouillet ce coup pour le
merveilleux qui se développe à la fin du
xviie et bien va s'accompagner de
recherches sur l'île fusion un travail
sur les miroirs comment est-ce qu'on va
positionner les miroirs dans les salles
pour nous permettre d'avoir cette
impression que le décor s'étend à
l'infini tout ça ce sont des éléments
qu'on retrouve dans les dé dans les
décors a décrit dans les comptes de fait
pour découvrir cette exposition il vous
faudra environ 45 minutes pour déambuler
dans les cinq pièces aménagées pour
l'occasion des décors qui font écho à
l'histoire du château de rambouillet
puisqu'il s'agit d'un appartement
aménagé justement dans cette première
moitié du xviiie siècle où se développe
l'art rococo et vous pourrez découvrir
dans cet appartement de merveilleuses
boiseries rocaille installée depuis
début novembre dans le château cette
scénographie destiné à un public
familial pour ces fêtes de fin d'année
j'invite vraiment les familles à venir
et à découvrir avec les enfants ces
différents décors qui rappellera
justement tous ces contes de fées qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui parfaitement et qui
sont issus de cette période du 17 sites
fin de la fin du xviie et du début du
xviiie siècle l'exposition est à
découvrir jusqu'au 6 mars pour un tarif
de 9 euros 50 avec un seul mot d'ordre
laisser libre cours à son imagination
le festival électro chic revient pour
une sixième édition du 19 mars 2022 sur
le territoire versailles grand parc des
artistes de renom mais aussi à des
artistes émergents viendront faire vivre
et le public sur de la musique électro
un membre de l'équipe nous en parle
[Musique]
évidemment un festival électro s'adresse
d'abord à ceux qui aiment l'électro mais
du fait de ma programmation
pluridisciplinaire on a aussi l'espoir
de toucher
des publics qui ne viendraient pas
spontanément l'électro
aujourd'hui est une musique
extrêmement intéressant par toutes les
facettes qu'elle développe
et par la complexité des sons qu'elle
proposait en même temps la beauté qui
s'exprime
nous aurons plusieurs artistes nous
aurons arnaud rebotini je vous en parle
et nous aurons six minagri gorioux
thierry balasse
la dietrich
nous organisons un jury chaque année
chargée d'auditionner les
candidatures
d'un certain nombre de jeunes musiciens
auxquels nous proposons de jouer en live
en direct devant le public
[Musique]
lors d'une des soirées du festival
et c'est la fin de ses 7,8 culture merci
de nous avoir suivis bonne soirée sur
tv77
[Musique]